although this year's nominees for live
action short film come from five
different countries they addressed
Universal and highly recognizable
dilemmas these films are about deeply
relevant and contemporary topics like a
simulation and dislocation when to
challenge authority and the difficulty
of making meaningful connections in the
modern world let's take a look at the
nominees for the best live-action short
term enemy interior Salim
SSE Nizam Ellis is a team of volunteers
and Jacqueline qudoos silent night
Escobar and Kim Magnussen sing feast of
dark and Anna Oh daddy
timecode one whole female and the Oscar
goes to sing
[Music]
this is the first Oscar and nomination
for Christoph - and honor guard a
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you so much
to the Academy for this incredible award
I have to be quick and there are a lot
of people to thank firstly my family and
my teachers who raised me and taught me
how to be a good person and my wife as
well and on behalf of Anna as well my
wonderful cast and crew and this is
dedicated to all the only people who can
basically make the world a better place
for us kids so let's try and raise them
in a good way
try and raise them in a way we can be
proud of them thank you
[Applause]